so we got a lot of new people on last  season I'm going to direct this one of  you jog are willing to see some new  faces in the new season  yeah I've been waiting all day too so  yeah so you know the end of last year we  hinted a couple times at Clifford to  vote coming on tour big bad this year is  the thinker and the Neil mandolin is  from the hundred you may know from the  hundred is going to play the thinker  he's amazing in words so we also have  speaking of gypsy and and and five Japan  author preacher is going to show up and  be why to be played by Danny Trejo  bomb in the rock my god what did you  feel like what you heard that that was  going to be her death  [Laughter]  usually where many members of your  audience yeah there's also one more  there's another role along with the  thicker called and she is going to be  played by Kim and Engelbrecht so or have  a nice little killing as well  [Applause]  you